in the 21st century nothing is more
dangerous than ignorance and the most
dangerous kind of ignorance for Jews is
ignorance of Islam Islam has a lot to
say about various groups Jews Christians
polytheists women and so on and it's
important for these groups to understand
what Islam says about them because what
Islam says about them will have an ever
increasing impact on their groups as
Islam spreads the Quran contains
numerous verses about Jews some nice and
some not so nice and the quran's claims
about Jews have been affecting Jewish
Muslim relations for 14th centuries for
Jewish viewers who would like to know
what Islam says about them but don't
have much time to study the Muslim
sources I've put together the shortest
possible list of relevant Quran verses
there are dozens of Quran verses about
Jews that we could examine but we're
going to focus on just three all from
the same chapter Surah 5 keep in mind
that we'll only be talking about what
Islam and ideology claims not what a
particular Muslim believes if you're a
Jew you may have a Muslim friend or
coworker who's the nicest person in the
world and who has no problem with you or
with your religion or with Israel we're
not discussing what individuals believe
we're discussing what Islam teaches and
we can get a nice overview by reading
just just three verses our first verse
is Surah
5:32 even if you've never studied Islam
you've probably heard part of this verse
at some point because it's one of the
most frequently quoted Quran verses in
the West after every Islamic terrorist
attack politicians and journalists
remind us that such attacks are unlam
because the Quran declares that if
anyone kills a man it's as if he's
killed all mankind they never quote the
complete verse of course and they almost
never give the reference because if they
gave the reference someone might read
the complete verse and even worse might
read the very next verse watch what
happens when we read the entire verse
this is how Sora 5 verse 32 is usually
quoted To Us by politicians and
journalists if anyone killed a person it
would be as if he killed all
mankind sometimes they include a bit
more telling us that the Quran says
if anyone killed a person it would be as
if he killed all mankind and if anyone
saved a life it would be as if he saved
the life of all
mankind but let's see what politicians
and journalists leave out because of
that we ordained for the children of
Israel that if anyone killed a person
not in retaliation of murder or to
spread Mischief in the land it would be
as if he killed all mankind and if
anyone saved a life it would be as if he
saved the life of all
mankind and indeed there came to them
our Messengers with clear proofs
evidences and signs even then after that
many of them continued to exceed the
limits EG by doing oppression unjustly
and exceeding beyond the limits set by
Allah by committing the major sins in
the land notice four things about this
verse one
the Quran says that this was a
revelation for Jews the children of
Israel we ordained for the children of
Israel that if anyone killed a person
not in retaliation of murder or to
spread Mischief in the land it would be
as if he killed all
mankind and we know what the Quran is
referring to here this is a quotation
from a Jewish rabbi in the talmud the
Quran says that Allah ordained this for
the children of Israel politicians and
journalists omit the part about the
children of Israel so that they can
pretend that Islam calls for Endless
peace and tolerance meanwhile the very
next verse Surah
5:33 is a revelation for Muslims and it
commands Muslims to dismember and kill
and crucify all kinds of people so 533
justifies terrorism politic Ians and
journalists ignore it and go to
532 they do a bit of editing and there
you have it Islam is a religion of
Peace two since this is the standard
verse quoted by Muslim apologists and
politicians and journalists to show that
Islam is a religion of Peace we should
always point out that the most peaceful
verse in the Quran is actually a
quotation from the
talmud three the Quran says that this
Jewish teaching is a revelation from
Allah so according to the Quran the
talmud or at least a portion of it is a
revelation from Allah just as the Torah
and The Gospel According to the Quran
are Revelations from Allah commentary
from a rabbi in the talmud is revelation
from Allah good to know for the Quran
says that there was an exception to the
rule against killing and that Jews could
execute people for spreading mischief
in the land if anyone killed a person
not in retaliation of murder or to
spread Mischief in the land it would be
as if he killed all
mankind so Jews according to the Quran
had Authority from Allah to carry out
capital punishment for certain crimes
committed in the land pop quiz for those
of you who read the Quran which land is
the Quran referring to here is it a
Canada B China C Switzerland or D Israel
Allah according to the Quran gave the
children of Israel authority over the
land of Israel yes Allah is a Zionist
who says that the children of Israel
have the right to punish people for
spreading Mischief in the
land can you think of anyone who's been
land next verse Surah 5 verse 43 the
historical background of this verse is
that some Jews came to Muhammad to judge
a dispute Allah responded by saying to
Muhammad but how do they come to you
Muhammad for decision while they have
the torat the Torah in which is the
plain decision of Allah yet even after
that they turn away for they are not
really
Believers Allah wanted to know why Jews
would come to Muhammad when they already
had the Torah
Muhammad gives a dramatic illustration
of Allah's point in Sun Abu 4449 where
we see Muhammad's reaction to the Jews
coming to him for judgment in 7th
Century Arabia the person who judged a
dispute would sit on a judgment cushion
watch what Muhammad
does they set out a cushion for the
messenger of Allah and he sat on it then
he said bring me the Torah it was
brought and he took the cushion from
beneath him and placed the Torah on it
and said I believe in you and in the one
who revealed you so the Jews bring a
copy of the Torah Muhammad takes the
Judgment cushion out from under him and
puts the Torah on the Judgment cushion
Muhammad speaks to the Torah and says I
believe in you and in the one who
revealed you according to the Quran do
Jews need Muhammad's
Revelations no because they already have
the Torah the Quran then is useless to
Jews according to the Quran
itself notice also that both Muhammad
and Allah affirm the inspiration
preservation and continuing authority of
the Torah third verse Surah 5 verse
82 verily you will find the strongest
among men in enmity to the Believers I.E
Muslims the Jews and those who are Al
musun musun are people who associate
partners with Allah and you will find
the nearest in love to the Believers I.E
Muslims those who say we are Christians
that is because amongst them are priests
and monks and they are not proud so the
greatest enemies of Muslims according to
Sur 5 verse 82 of the Quran are Jews and
those who associate partners with Allah
and the closest in love to Muslims are
Christians oddly enough Jews and
Christians are different groups from the
mushriks here Jews and Christians don't
associate partners with Allah later in
the Quran when Allah has to justify
violently subjugating Jews and
Christians he declares that Jews and
Christians are in fact
mushriks it's interesting how Allah's
Eternal Word the Quran changed depending
on how Muhammad was feeling
when Muhammad began receiving
revelations in Mecca the message of the
Quran was it's Muslims Jews and
Christians United as monotheists against
the polytheists later Muhammad and his
followers moved to Medina and it was a
very important test for Muhammad because
he had just spent a decade telling his
followers that the Jews would accept him
as a prophet Muhammad had assured his
followers that there were prophecies
about him in the Torah book of trust me
bro chap just take my word for it but
now that the Muslim Community had moved
to Medina where there were three tribes
of Jews Muslims finally had an
opportunity to see if Muhammad was right
in a shocking blow to Muhammad's ego the
Jews rejected him as a prophet and
mocked him for his
ignorance that's when the message of the
Quran changed to Muslims and Christians
are United against pagans and Jews as we
read in Surah 5 verse vers
82 eventually Christians also rejected
him as a prophet so The Message of Islam
became its Muslims against
everyone so Surah 5: 82 is from the
middle period when there was still hope
that Christians would accept Muhammad
again it's strange that an eternal book
would be so heavily influenced by
Muhammad's interactions with
non-muslims sadly the Quran claim that
Jews are among the greatest enemies of
Islam because they rejected Muhammad has
had a lasting impact on many Muslims and
even on their view of future events in
sah Muslim number 7339 Muhammad says the
hour the day of judgment will not begin
until the Muslims fight the Jews and the
Muslims will kill them until a Jew hides
behind a rock or a tree and the rock or
tree will say oh Muslim oh slave of
Allah there is a Jew behind me come and
kill him putting all of this together
the Quran says that Jews were given not
only Revelations from Allah including
the Torah and the talmud but also a
piece of land where Jews can enforce
their laws against those who make
Mischief the Quran says that Jews don't
need Muhammad because they have the
Torah The Inspired preserved
authoritative word of Allah but for some
reason even though Muhammad and the
Quran are useless to Jews they're still
supposed to acknowledge Muhammad as a
prophet since they don't Islam declares
that Jews will be the enemies of Muslims
until Muslims kill them to usher in the
end times not very comforting but that's
what we find when we read the Muslim
sources now if I were a Jew and I knew
what Islam teaches about Jews and I saw
the impact that Muhammad's teachings
have on the world
I would probably spend some time
responding to what the Quran says about
me and my family and my community and if
anyone asked me why are you criticizing
the Quran I would calmly Reply look the
Quran talked about me and my family and
my community long before I said a word
about the Quran and if you don't think
that I have every right to respond to
Islam's most trusted sources calling for
our violent
subjugation you have my full permission
to cry me a river I am not never have
been and never will be your
Demi deal with
[Music]
it